traditionally building any sort of
server technology has been pretty
difficult for any developer game
developers in particular like to focus
on the creative aspect of the game and
build more around the core game so from
a server perspective we we saw a cloud
computing as an opportunity to introduce
you know hands-off scalable on-demand
resources so game developers could focus
more on the game so what that means is
there's data centers all over the globe
and when you start up the game it
figures out where you are and what the
best connection to which data center you
have is
one of the advantages of cloud computing
is the elastic scalability the idea that
compute exists in the cloud when you
need it it'll spin up a server a
dedicated server in a server farm
basically for you on a fast connection
with you know fast CPUs it makes
matchmaking really quick and then once
you're in the game it's a really
consistent experience you don't have
people doing lag switch killing you
don't have host migration you have just
solid gameplay that's fair for everybody
if anyone asked for a server just throw
them a server throw my server throw my
server and we replenish that pool from
the cloud and so we need another one we
just grab the down put in our pool and
hand it out to somebody
so it's this constantly available you
know set of servers all over the globe
when they fun
one of the things we're seeing that's
really amazing about titanfall is the
idea that a lot of the AI and the non
player character is actually powered by
the server that would not be feasible to
do on a game that's client hosted so
they have this ability to adapt over
time change and tweak the game even
after the discs have shipped without
sort of interrupting a user gameplay or
you know making users download big
patches and things of that nature it's a
more even experience there's no host
advantage there's no you know kind of
worry about who's hosting what and you
know do we have to now reserve
performance on everybody's machines we
can maximize what we're doing knowing
full well that on the back end we have
power there take advantage of the game
the first time I think users are seeing
why server technology is really going to
make next-generation gaming that much
better
you